he's the former acting deputy secretary
of the dhs
and a heritage foundation visiting
fellow welcome ken
um let's just be with you thank you
let's just talk really quick
what do you think about all these
changing policies i mean your
administration or the trump
administration
works so hard to put them in place and
they're just being dismantled right
before our eyes
what's going to happen well i mean it's
already happening
we've got an invasion going on at the
southern border
and mind you this is all happening and
in two weeks we're going to be talking
about their hr1 bill right
which eliminates penalties for illegal
aliens voting in elections so
let's not kid ourselves about what the
path
plan here is this is about democrats
believing they can just create
voters by abandoning the law and
i agree with your your last visitor you
know american hispanics they own
businesses
they have families they have religious
beliefs they're like other americans
and they they they want a country of
laws too
and that has uh that is being ripped
apart
systematically and very quickly uh by
the biden administration and very
intentionally
uh with a purpose yeah and you know they
believe that it's a path to maintaining
their own power
yeah i was just gonna say you know
hispanics along that border so many
hispanics are
are business owners they're the you know
the most entrepreneurial demographic
in america their businesses have been
shut down purportedly because of kovid
we need to lock down that's what the
democrats say um and
then you know they're seeing people come
across the border so
lock down our economy lock down our
people um
and then open the borders it makes it
makes zero sense i want to show you this
clip from
newt gringer's take a look and then give
me your reaction on the other side
oh i'm sorry it's not a click that's a
read so here we go there's no excuse for
razor wire to be blocking the american
people from our capital
it is the people's house the fencing is
more than an eyesore
it's an insult so um no borders
no walls at the border but then you know
what about our work nancy knows it
nancy knows it walls work and so if it's
to protect nancy
it's a good wall just like federal
police officers
who are fighting left-wing rioters are
nazi
stormtroopers to nancy pelosi but
they're heroes if they're protecting
nancy pelosi i think they're all heroes
and i think walls work because we've
proved it whether it's at the capitol or
the border
we'd be better off moving that wall to
the border
it's already funded by the way if they
would let the funds roll to that
uh it's it's really a pathetic
comparison
uh and it really belies
their underlying motives and it also
ropes in another one of their
political canards and that's that they
somehow have to be protected
from everyone on the right they're doing
magnetometers because republicans are
dangerous coming onto the floor right
oh just one insult after another i don't
know
i don't know why these congressmen can
people and the wisdom of the american
people
that they see through this they
understand what's going on um
and in part because of how brazen
they're being about it
yeah i i was just going to say again
that i can't understand
why kevin mccarthy or any of these
congressmen will stand for walking
through those magnetometers it is an
insult
not just to them but to the voters that
put them in office um
it's it's like saying they're all
domestic terrorists that's an important
connection
yeah that's a very important connection
to make and
there are people fighting it congressman
clyde's fighting it louie gohmert is
fighting it there are others who would
like to
the fines are so big that um
but you can expect to see more on that
they're going to keep fighting that and
we're going to be very proud of them all
right thank you ken really appreciate
you joining us this evening up next